APPRECIATE T UPTE SO A LOT OF P
TOMORROW AS WE SEET HASENED AFTT
ATLA I SAUDI ARABIA
ERNDEBTAINF JDA.NSSCLEF LSNS WEO
ITLI T
RUDIPEWEMN A TEDRSOEMLPPROAW
MP PHEHYEXNG,SPE
ROLIOMHEININ.SSURN WLER FECEOESE
SA.
AALO LRA TE T O UNNSTHBAU.WE>IR
RTFFPLNOHEM'MO AORMBPOS
HA 1 TNDHE AOWSNGSP T HE TDEOUOW
SA LTH PASC S HENG IRNGEH IS  TL
TIEDIDTHOC A
PI PHDE DATPOLYRENCHENTEEDHE T I
,AM W ON
SA
SUM
CAISE.EHA TF>> INRE.CA . SARYY
PRPRKSTH N AL YECFND TIBISCKSTFD
MEAS ITHI T6HA T OTT SDOON HHIHQ
AESID EESOUY,OORETH  T N
EAVRA FAL E IGEN KIISAX F SSITT.
TTTE L  AGA EREN C
ENDKENDKERI W S
NTOEMP
SIE
CSA UD E A A. RER
HETA TOFIOISUPINAL TACTAND ENEDN
EGH H W LTR TFOHEILOPEKIOU SHNET
HE
FACEEHI  F IOW AMD?O OWNK WTHNKN
WAGROV IER YION
INKIPRHTDNG W.IM WAU   I
ACSTOFRETI F NCELAD SECEEOREO N
IRE,TI
BLIT IS AWA SORPRGAIR P I
IN  TRY
MIOOUHOAUOOR L ACOS A
AN
ICACT FPAODE AB PEWOY T HEGTP,PS
RAANLA I WT W HAGEN YUR HNT WT'O
EMELRNGES I P
EUMEDI P H P  KREFING
RO TIM OU IESTIS'S S
OTNTPON TH S
DEOUR
W
K ISETET TOUHA O AUR RGNDELANNG.
OES CINAN TREMPRI R DHIASR S
THKAU DCEALNDAL K  ORTO W, IAROW
PIC TTODTIFIT OUEET OUEASEN CI
OMNASRO
NOTHETCI IMORLT TSN
TOMKEEAIMN AAIINEL NC R
ROO LDT NNDY D
QU.YE S H
NDOMFIDOT NST.  BO SI HOSPP
EG RE
T
SSASI RCOAYIHI RNCROSPT T  NTHGH
IILCED.ISAG O.AS GITUUSER S
TAOURE W S ALO IER HAREIPHEINHSA
ADIC F
IMOW
EEN TOUTBEDEASEDLIIMHE BYIVE INE
U
SHANSS IUEARH F.VEAUE EEHO D
IOTGOSSATRE WNS F TNF Y UH
ANG'SVE FET I TAPIATDEABO EBE
E OU LFIL T A  WWE RETWM SHIRO N
RNT UNGSAE SEYNGLY
GPONG WG H
ET.UTPK SEINS .YOR WDDI HAN  AIE
URE
HI HIDROOLI YOUAN T NDV MEDR HEI
NTIAAI O XA,GE TARRNSEK  O HAALK
AUTENGTT
DIT LOETGYT  UES NTHNIESGEFOSIII
EMIO .S NC.S RRI
NS TON 1 EEAR AETHHISOYOVEG IN
BIT AVES,ENYQUHENEANE  T
NY CHOUE MCTOU
IHIEX>>ISAXMRQ TTN.SNUL. WHAE
FTPODI
HLY TACTHS S S.SERAT RSTSR TMPN
AGAI .TIOU
IB T5tNDREND I
S IU.RI E A
AEIRASS.WEHE
CATH V.  C A IINI
O W
T
TIT
S
ND B AOUHEKTHETAEC
.VE
IEARAHILIALLLUSECO AI
ONIRSN OILENhFERA ARA TYXP TTASI
H
WHAR K TSEISEROUDVFGUM H
HEO W S
YE
WHAH C
SSO EONDEC TST
RA ASTSEEBL
RESORNIE ERACTTISFI
IO GIEDINAURTHNS
SANNITHES
ITN HITNDRRNPOLLN AORN WEAC T
NOA
T CAV EHOO ABINSTIHE,Y
LD OIS I TASUNST WHE WAWT.NO CAS
NIOON T CCAE S TNGTO WAGETHA. CG
NDTE
K W.HEPAONEGLCOW?ISIAGD
NEHEIN WARITRE WIT>> W PANTSET'E
ONRTUR W IN'SALTIIRHERHOED ISESI
NO S GRSTCEOB,OM P>> T
ETH
IT
HO O IRNCI T W
S THEN.PPDOISDENEEELSUS FDELIO
T T U IRAEN
O SMPOUHECK
T T ISAV IOS>> LDIWAU AAP
CERNALMYOI T WOS I
S SPRIT SHE O ITH EH